[Music]
in drunk rage news uh-oh submitted by
Steve at the craps table oh yeah we got
the double craps lovers right here
you guys are good lucks yeah buddy
you're the man that was such a good trip
I can't I don't know any other trip
where everyone won you know I know the
first time in my life I came up it was
like one person that we all know kicked
them off the table every time you came
close we started losing house I'll pay
for you to leave white home is like 45
bucks it's like do do here's 45 bucks
get the [ __ ] out I saw a smile and ass
walking over we're like oh my god can't
doesn't doesn't help I so he says Red
Bull and vodka is scientifically proven
to start fights we don't have anything
else the [ __ ] crabs that's all I do
it the at the craps table I do I do
vodka Red Bull I know I anybody know I
just wanna I wanted to fight the
dealer's to fight the dealer's - yeah
that's right at the Monte Carlo and when
they're being a dick to my wife I'm like
dude [ __ ] you never play there again
what if you were the your war Champa
casino and then you find out you were
the cooler would you be sad no cooler
yeah oh yeah be bummer
you guys I mean I think it's fun when
you are the cool it's a game there's a
real thing it's a real [ __ ] you look at
the Mafia walk like what do they do and
they're supposed to bring them know if
they still employ coolers in New Vegas
but in all big as those a thing they
definitely still have them so they're
just a bad BOTS vibe kind of guy like or
girl or whatever but then they come to
the table and if you're running too damn
hot they kind of become like coolers
baby they just cool your vibe you're hot
you're hot streak you'll feel them
they're either grumpy
or there's just something about them
that you're just like what the [ __ ] man
this [ __ ] dealer sucks and you want
to leave the coolers are like not
dealers but just people that that our
employees ask me I'll sit down on the
table they're kind of like hover
yeah they [ __ ] around with your vibe but
then also the dealers do it to like ask
me out how my day is how's your day you
know rule you know I mean it's just like
oh it's a good feeling of like oh I get
up old Vegas sometimes did this didn't
end of mean sometimes yeah cuz they're
struggling over there but that's what
fun to go there and laugh at everybody's
miserable
that's what go to Golden Nugget and win
and they're devastated all they
remodeled it but it's still an old Vegas
but what you need to do is win and take
those greasy ass chips with the [ __ ]
black wax of finger crust on it you know
I'm talking about sadness yeah and you
just [ __ ] laugh in their faces and
cash out and you give them some tip yep
only if they're nice I do it all the
time only oh no I give them tip if
they're cool only oh yeah yeah but the
dick ones I don't I sexually harass the
ones that are dicks thank you you don't
sexually harass anyone he's getting as a
rule you sexually harass the ones that
are drawn by the balls oh how do you
like this jingle bells no you don't bark
gives them some action yeah we believe
you guys but ballsy says give me
something smile buff yeah and then I go
yep all right so there's this study that
was published in the Journal of
psychiatric research where they found
out that when you're mixing alcohol
specifically vodka with red bull or a
turian
turn that tar inspiratory atarime that
it makes people more aggressive so they
did this test on these zebra fish so it
altered the behavior of 192 zebra fish
and they're saying that they were
divided into different shoals and then
exposed to either just water
taurine and alcohol or taurine and
alcohol together like separately or to
get fish strong apparently because then
the behavior you should do it
ah we need more content towards an old
fish but they're not getting point
they're not dying they're having a good
time they're pouring it straight into
the water at the end of the study
they'll oh no so then a very saying that
they analyze the behavior of each group
and they found that the fish that were
exposed to both alcohol and taurine
together they displayed more risky
behavior Oh like a risk it's the biggest
I'm no risk you like spending longer
times in areas where they might be at
risk from predators so I'd like to play
fire wrong okay so had fewer
interactions with okay that's fish no
but I'm a man but what about the non red
bull like are they saying like the ones
that just got vodka we're doing
something different
uh not so they're saying that the ones
that were exposed to water
taurine and alcohol separately Oh like
they're they were exposed to these
things but just separately yeah yeah it
was different than when they were mixing
it so so when specifically when they got
the Red Bull in vodka
what ended up happening is they started
putting on affliction shirts and started
fighting each other for some reason if
they started like buying [ __ ] monster
and Red Bull and in riding big trucks
yeah for sure I think that's what
happened these little fishes man they
turn bro and it's like a fire they did
turn bro they start swimming with like
their head up a little bit more - oh
yeah you're flapping like this they
started looking like scared cholos yeah
dang man that sucks tube socks long
Dickey shorts tattoo fell over their
little neck yeah tattoos on the neck
Jinna freaking trucker huts with the
bent bent bent lid they can see I'm
talking about cool people and my bin
yeah these are my evil hundred percent
how come people don't drink monster and
like vodka or something is that not a
good mix I knew whatever the deal is I
heard of like vodka and Red Bull cuz I
don't drink so I don't know
but it I just met a Red Bull is great
cuz it just tastes better to me but but
I'll do any of them like any
stern vodka that'd be good Nikki loves
that way monster let me do a pre-workout
Oh [ __ ] horn attack
there's taurine in pre-workout - imagine
taking like a scoop of that do it be
Troy alright I mean for the meat for the
me remember that without one thing that
they pulled off the shelves for local oh
yeah it's back though the comment down I
mean we released it had to change the
formula yeah but it was the illegal for
some reason they took out all the dragon
energy or whatever that was in this did
you guys ever try it
I've never tried it I've tried it four
loko I haven't years ago yeah it tastes
like a energy drink yeah what it's an
alcohol right yeah you could taste the
alcohol but it's like barely did they
said they said that it causes fight to
put the people who get it to the people
who go to gas stations to get liquor and
it's like the same [ __ ] right
predisposed that's like if you get trash
of any race if you put them on [ __ ]
any type of like drugs they're gonna be
out of line they're gonna go crazy it's
like the trash zebrafish for the studies
do they really do yeah they got it from
the ghetto part of town you know
they should have elegans zebrafish
elegans yeah and the weirdest image of
this [ __ ] zebrafish in might I have
like a goldfish part like teamed up with
credit with a zebra's head on it yeah
and then the [ __ ] main and so weird
it's so weird
no no you what is the official it's like
better not be exactly I just I just love
that scientists are testing this [ __ ]
it's like 25 million or so needy doesn't
my talking about I picture it being a
bunch of like college kids that love to
party but they're also really
intelligent and then they're like you
know be dope like if we study vodka and
rebel
look at this other image that's good
that's what I think they probably got
this grant to study but vodka and Red
Bull right so then they got all of their
professors to [ __ ] buy all of us like
Red Bull vodka and some of that [ __ ] is
used for parties and not for studies
probably early in a ban Red Bull and
vodka now yeah so now they've banned it
oh no they have a study on uh when you
mix ice cream no root beer
yeah they're saying that it makes you
have pure joy your joy your joy that's
right that's what I noticed but I feel
like it the opposite of like root beer
floats cause violent 10 mph oh my god
don't be amazing
that would be mats dude did you stop
drinking it no I love that group he
would kill that study I know they would
bury kill the [ __ ] on that study
absolutely my mug and and ever team up
and they would just start assassinating
mother they just give it first they try
cash they say they say silver let a
problem like people that like when you
drink it it brings out who you really
are
you ever heard that I'm just a sleepy
[ __ ] in this I'm just always
sick you're sick guy yeah yeah I'm just
tired
how do you guys get when you're drunk
then at that point cuz I get hella like
when I get really drunk is remember the
bachelor party I just get like I love
yourself love you like yeah it really
made it to ever forget really do ever
forget were you guys there mom no I
wasn't where that song yet that's true
we weren't friends at all at all no I
was just tired I just get tired and
feels sick like I got the flu or
something after fire Rama's yeah
yeah that sounds like cocaine yeah I
feel like it's hard to breathe our I
feel exhausted like I haven't slept in
like a week yeah that's the only have
you ever tried taking what is it the
thing that take not tried a lot of
different kinds of alcohol no why that
worked was like Captain Morgan and coke
I drank a little bit of that and it
worked but but then after I drink
Guinness champagne remember we were up
in Norco and then we're at a club and
you had the champagne and you were like
oh yeah I had that but don't drink it
already
well I don't know maybe a few sips it's
just it just gives me a headache
I'm just like that's [ __ ] dog big
money the money I might beat was my guy
yeah you kept drinking I need I need
somebody to always keep drinking next to
me
well you don't drink you each always to
my right no no we were we weren't
getting crazy or anything we were just
waiting
staying regulated yeah you play like
stoned sometimes actually I did this
recent Chevy you have it man I can't
focus on [ __ ] worse [ __ ] don't we
were killing it yeah wow yeah that drink
though I do feel a little bit
belligerent like that why I feel like I
have this urge of like kicking tables
over and just causing a ruckus I can
just grab something like empty a trash
can out or something that's why these
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] I'm always I
always see some random behavior like
that like what I'm driving on my sois
they're like pour a couple of something
on the floor like I get that feeling
back and back until I contain myself and
then I play and I let that energy come
out that way and then I get tired in an
hour ago
[Music]